[Music]
chapter three of fortnite battle royale
sees the imagined order go to war with
the seven for control of the zero point
and all versions of reality the seven
led by the foundation have begun an
uprising inspiring the loopers to fight
and to bring their scattered members
back together but this war will not be
easy io won't give up they've controlled
the island the loop and the bridge for
thousands of years it's time for the
first live event of chapter three and
here's everything you need to know
before collision
[Music]
to fully understand the mess we found
ourselves in we need to travel back to
chapter two and the day agent jones
abandoned the i o and joined the seven
jones in fear of losing the zero point
recalibrated his portal device to bring
the foundation to reality zero after a
shaky start the two worked together to
stabilize the nexus and after a few more
adventures the two joined forces and
flipped the island our new home was
peaceful and serene for a while until
the day sloan arrived using scouting
drills the imagined order ripped through
to the top side and began reconnaissance
watching from the shadows waiting for
their time to strike
around this time the scientists
desperately attempted to reunite the
members of the seven bringing them
together to face this impending threat
of io but nothing worked their
infighting and distrust was going to be
the downfall of reality we are the seven
we have a duty to rise above grudges and
petty disagreements for the greater good
and yes foundation i'm looking at you i
can see your face through that mask
[Music]
without warning seismic activity could
be felt underfoot and before we knew it
io had constructed a base like no other
covert cavern a hollowed-out mountain
crammed with everything they could need
to seize control of the island plus some
unexplained secrets behind 50-foot vault
doors sealed shut from prying eyes sloan
gunner and the rest of the troops stayed
as stealthy as possible and continue to
disrupt the island's communications
constantly ruining the scientists
attempts to prepare for war monitoring
comes jamming space missions and
removing the looper's ability to build
the day sloane was waiting for finally
arrived
[Music]
io declared war and the fortress hit the
surface loopers immediately fought for
their new home and friends from other
realities joined the fight too seemingly
overnight the imagined order seized
around 80 of the island from tilted
towers to condo canyon the io flag flew
controlling the high ground using
airships the war was almost over within
a day thankfully a few pockets of
resistance stood strong the seven's home
of sanctuary remained intact well almost
and the scientists created a new poi
synapse station as a new resistant
stronghold this became a makeshift
workshop repurposing battle bus shells
and stolen i o tanks and flipping them
to the resistance cause another poi held
by the joneses remained under the
seventh watch but the jones clones here
made a stand they refused to take part
in the war only one jon jones still
fights to this day former i o agent
jones the same man who started this
uprising all those seasons ago
[Music]
thankfully other members of the seven
are now on the island on day one of the
war both the origin and the imagined
were on hand to lead the way the origin
is a skilled tactician who is in charge
of the seven's fight back and the
military leader of the loopers over
weeks and months he sent us onto the
field to disrupt the i o offensive and
slowly we took down the imagined
daughter strongholds replacing their
flag with our own you did good work
today
reality saving work maybe the origin has
a secret backstory to uncover which will
explain why he looks the way he does
before the origin took his place in the
seven he was the cube king
it's true the origin was once cube
royalty leading the cult of the last
reality before we met the queen in the
chapter 2 finale the origin was
responsible for the destruction of
countless realities but somehow he was
able to disconnect from the hive mind
and escape with his life the ever
watchful imagined order took this
opportunity to capture the origin
imprisoning him and extracting
information about the power of the cubes
we've seen how sloan interrogates
prisoners whilst a prisoner the origin
shared a cell block with another member
of the seven the paradigm but we'll get
back to that very soon eventually the
seven rescued the origin and offered him
a place in their ranks from that day
forward the origin vowed to save every
world he could and oppose the tyranny of
the last reality and the imagined order
two more members of the seven arrived
this season the sisters named the
imagined and the order i'm sure you've
noticed they literally have the same
name as the bad guys we may want to
watch these two i mean if they meet in
game they say this i'm working on our
next big heist i mean military plan that
sounds frighteningly ominous from day
one the imagined has done things her own
way she has this uncanny ability to take
a solid plan from the origin or
scientist and improve upon it her only
problem is she has no recollection of
her past her memories are a complete
blur truth is
i don't remember anything about my past
at all but i believe in what the seven
is doing
and i'm here she's assisted in the war
effort all season but spends the
majority of her time attempting to find
out about her own history at one point
we helped her access the i o database to
find more information about herself and
her sister the imagined is a strong
believer in the paradigm she's aware of
her poor reputation but firmly stands by
her friend and this is the issue we find
the seven's inability to get along is
causing serious issues there are two
major camps in the resistance those who
want paradigm to rejoin the group and
those who distrust her and think she's a
threat to reality the scientist and the
imagined are firmly pro-paradigm yet the
foundation and the origin are
unconvinced let's try and break down
what we know so far back to chapter one
we go
before the final showdown we watched
singularity oversee the creation of the
mecca team leader this was created to
protect the island from imminent attack
since then it has been confirmed the
paradigm was the pilot of that mech that
day as she's the most skilled aviator in
their ranks we can't 100 confirm this
but it's heavily hinted that singularity
and the paradigm are the same person and
potentially a double agent it's highly
likely the reason paradigm is mistrusted
by the seven is due to this choice here
deliberately destabilizing reality and
cracking the zero point in battle if she
was there to protect the orb why
threaten reality by destabilizing it the
origin says she's a traitor but in my
opinion i'd say the evidence is
circumstantial at best we could argue
the rush of energy the mech claimed in
that moment was exactly what it needed
to defeat the devourer or on the other
hand that decision is exactly why
reality is in danger right now setting
us on a course of events that lead to
this very moment another theory is that
paradigm is a double agent working for
the imagined order and the seven this
has evidence to back it up when the
origin was captured by the imagined
order he grew to know another prisoner
in the next cell that was the paradigm
one day the paradigm escaped her prison
cell and left the origin behind this
feeling of abandonment manifested into
distrust how could a mech pilot break
out of a cell he could not the origin is
convinced she's a traitor because she
broke out of a prison he had to be
rescued from he thinks she had inside
help but he has no proof
old men in their hunches i guess and
even if he did have proof
i believe people can change
i just i have to believe that this seed
of distrust threatens the unity of the
seven and this will all come to a head
at the next live event because the mech
is being rebuilt as we speak this is the
seven's last chance to work as a team
and save our reality which brings us to
the collider
[Music]
the imagined order were winning this war
from the first bullet yet two months
later they hold on by a thread desperate
times call for desperate measures and
overnight the collider rose up a machine
which pulses with seismic energy at
regular intervals jones a former i o
agent was able to share information
about this poi this is a doomsday
machine this will not come as a surprise
but i o management loves doomsday
machines
awesome there's even a doomsday division
at hq oh
man their softball team is awful but
they will one day destroy us all so
kind of a wash the imagined order are
planning to terminate everything in the
loop in our last mission for the origin
we infiltrated io's war room and ran a
simulation to see what the future holds
everything in the loop
gone
just like that
i won't watch another world end we are
going to win this
agent jones wasn't done there his old i
o credentials allowed him to delve into
classified files while looking into the
imagine's memory loss he found this
look into the sisters the less i
understand the imagine especially seems
really really into finding old i o
personnel files see if we can figure out
what she's looking for someone else is
looking through these files and judging
by what i'm saying
they're looking at the same data i'm
seeing records for the foundation the
origin the paradigm but nothing on the
sisters again
jones tells us someone has deleted the
files on both sisters the imagined and
the order and he even gives us the name
of the culprit
this is only the third time we've heard
that name i can get you to geno you
promised me geno the live event should
finally give us information about the
mysterious geno and his links to both io
and the seven
[Music]
it's time for the final showdown the
seven have pushed back the imagined
order who will make their final stand at
the collider the mecca team leader is
officially recommissioned and sits in
our lobby screen at a secret moon base
we know the paradigm will be making
improvements to the mech and maybe some
new attire for the loopers too on the
island we have many unanswered questions
what is behind the vault doors in the
command cavern will the drift arm be
important to the story and what about
the devourers corpse all this is
happening while the seven continue to
bicker about the loyalty of the paradigm
they may be too distracted to notice the
real double cross going on here
[Music]
our questions will be answered on june
the 4th i'm adam you're awesome thanks
for watching